اتفقت السعوديه وايران على استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح
السفارتين والممثليات الدبلوماسيه في غضون
شهرين وتم التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق عقب
مباحثات جرت في بيجين مع الرئيس الصيني
وتضمنت اتفاق البلدين تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني بينهما والاحترام المتبادل
والالتزام بعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما السياقات التي دفعت
باتجاه التوصل لهذا الاتفاق وما العوامل
التي لعبت دورا في اتمامه بالنظر للوقت
الطويل الذي استغرقته جوله الحوار بين
الجانبين في العراق
كذلك اي دلاله للاعلان من الصين عن
الاتفاق وما طبيعه المفاوضات التي جرت بين
الطرفين هناك والتي افضت لابرام هذا
التفاهم وكيف نفهم ذلك في ضوء التطورات في
المنطقه
واخيرا ما الانعكاسات المنتظره لهذا
الاتفاق على الاقليم بخاصه الملفات التي
يلعب فيها البلدان دورا مهما لاسيما اليمن
[موسيقى]
سبع سنوات من القطيعه الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وايران وضعت اوزارها في الصين ذا
كما قاله بيان مشترك بين طهران والرياض
وبيجين
قال ان البلدين اتفقا في مباحثات قادها
رئيس مجلسي الامن القومي فيهما بدعم صيني
على طي صفحه الخلافات بينهما والتطبيع
العلاقات التي شهدت توترات على خلفيه
ملفات اهمها الحرب في اليمن
والنفوذ الاقليميه
تصريحات المسؤولين في البلدين جاءت لتؤكد
التوجه الجديد في اداره العلاقه بينهما
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان قال ان دول المنطقه يجمعها مصير
واحد يجعل من الضروره ان نتشارك لبناء
نموذج للازدهار اما مستشار الامن الوطني
السعودي مساعد العيبان قال من ناحيته انما
تم التوصل اليه من تاكيد احترام سياده
الدول يعد ركيزه اساسيه لتطور العلاقات
على الجانب الايراني قل وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه امير عبداللهيان ان سياسه حسن
الجوار امر محوري ونواصل العمل نحو مزيد
من الخطوات الاقليميه واضاف عبد الهيان ان
عوده العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه توفر
امكانات كبيره للمنطقه وللعالم الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من الدوحه
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث ومن طهران معنا محمد صالح
صدقيان الباحث المتخصص في القضايا
الاقليميه اهلا بكما فيما وراء الخبر ابدا
معك دكتور محمد صالح صدقيان
والسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه ما الذي جعل هذا
الاتفاق ممكننا فيما يبدو ان لا شيء على
الارض تغير
مساء الخير لك ليلى ولاضيفك الدكتور صقر
وللمشاهدين ان يعتقد باندا يجب ان نتذكر
ونرجع قليلا الى الوراء لان العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد احتضنت خمسه جولات من
المباحثات والحوارات الامنيه بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي توصل
الجانبان الى نقاط في غايه الاهميه خمس
جولات كانت مهمه من اجل استكشاف كما قال
الجانب السعودي استكشاف المواقع وكيف يمكن
الاتجاه قدما الى اعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين وانتهت هذه
الحوارات الى الاتفاق على ان تفتح حوارات
بين الجانبين حوارات دبلوماسيه بين الجانب
الايراني والجانب السعودي لكن المفاجاه
هنا قضيتين هو ان الصين دخلت على الخط
الثاني هو ان
سبقت الحوارات الدبلوماسيه ايضا حوارات
على الجانب الامني ويبدو لي بان
هذه يعني عاده العلاقات كانت بحاجه الى
حوارات امنيه من اجل وضع العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه على طريق الصحيح ويبدو
لي بان هذا
الاحتكاك الامني او التدافع الامني
الاقليمي هو الذي جعل
ان يتم التوقيع اولا بين مستشار الامن
القومي الايراني علي شوقاني ونظيره
السعودي من اجل
منائي يعني من اجل وضع العلاقات
المستقبليه على الجاده الصحيحه وانا اعتقد
بان ما تنف في الصين كان مهما جدا بالنسبه
الى طهران ومهما ايضا بالنسبه للرياض من
اجل وضوح وشفافيه الرؤيه المستقبليه
نحاول ان نفهم لماذا دكتور عبد العزيز
الصقر ما الدافع كما ذكر محمد صار صدقيان
ان جولات عديده في العراق وايضا عمان
استضافت بعض جلسات الحوار لم تسفر عن شيء
احتاج الامر الذهاب الى بيجين من اجل
الاعلان برايك انت الدافع مساء الخير لك
ست ليلى ولضيفك الكريم من طهران في
الحقيقه هنالك نقطتين اساسيه المملكه كانت
حافظها حينما قطعت العلاقه في عام 2016 تم
الاعتداء على السفاره السعوديه والقنصليه
وهذا خرق لاتفاقيات فيينا الدوليه
المعروفه في هذا الجانب والتي اشير لها في
مذكره التفاهم التي حدثت بين الطرفين
فالاجتماعات الامنيه السابقه والاستخباريه
التي تمت كان احد الاهداف منها التاكد من
ان الحكومه الايرانيه قادره على حمايه
المنشات الدبلوماسيه والدبلوماسيين
الموجودين بناء على الاتفاقيات الدوليه
لمنظمه لهذا الشيء لا سيما انه ايضا بعد
الاعتداء على السفاره السعوديه والقنصليه
هنالك اعتداء على سفارات اخرى في طهران
فهذه نقطه مهمه جدا يبدو ان هنالك تطمينات
وضمانات واضحه وكافيه النقطه الثانيه
والمهمه ايضا السعوديه ارادت ان تتناقش في
كثير من القضايا التي تهم الطرفين ولذلك
لاحظنا في البيان احترام السياده الخاصه
بالدول وهذه قضيه مهمه والعوده للموثيق
الدوليه في هذا الجانب النقطه بالنسبه
للمملكه هي توازن العلاقات الاقليميه
والدوليه هي اعاده ترتيب علاقاتها مع
تركيا هي الان تعيد ترتيب العلاقه مع
ايران هي تبحث فيما يتعلق بسوريا ومدى
وفاء سوريا بالتزاماته فهو اعاده ترتيب
مجمل قضايا المنطقه بشكل اوسع بالنسبه
لايران عانت من الفتره الماضيه من عزله
وهذه العزله كانت احد اسبابها الاساسيه
على العلاقه مع دول الجوار حينما تقدمت
ايران خطوه فبالتاكيد المملكه تقدمت خطوات
ايضا موازيه بهذا الاتجاه نحن نرى ان هذه
الاتفاق اهميته لانه يضع اسس مهمه عوده
الحوار الدبلوماسي المباشر بين الطرفين
واللي تم الاتفاق عليه انه خلال شهرين يتم
فتح السفارات ما بين الدولتين سوف يمكن
الطرفين من الحوار الدبلوماسي المباشر في
بحث مجمل القضايا اللي هي موجوده الصين هي
اكبر دوله اقتصاديه لها علاقه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ودول الخليج بشكل عام
حجم التجاره الصينيه مع دول الخليج يتجاوز
ال 130 بليون دولار اكثر من 36% من
احتياجات الصين للطاقه تاتي عبر دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ايضا هي الشريك الاكبر
لايران
الاقتصادي حينما زار الرئيس الصيني وكانت
القمه الصينيه الخليجيه العربيه السعوديه
في الرياض في ديسمبر طرحت قضيه ان ان على
الصين ان تلعب دور في المنطقه يختلف عن
دورها التقليدي وهو ابقاء المسافه
المتوازيه والمتساويه ما بين كل الاطراف
بمعنى ان اذا كان الازمه في اليمن هي بسبب
الدعم الايراني للح في اليمن فيجب على
الصين ان تمارس ضغوطها على ايران لكي يسود
الامن والاستقرار في منطقه هذه ولتلعب دور
الضامن فيما يتعلق بهذه القضايا طبعا
البيان الختامي الذي يعني اعلن في الرياض
في ديسمبر بعد زياده الرئيس الصيني تطرق
الى ايران والى اهميه العلاقه ربما استاءت
ايران من هذا البيان واستدعت السفير
الصيني في طهران ولكن بعدها قام الرئيس
الايراني بزياره الصين وبدت الجوله
والمحادثات من يناير تقريبا الى ان وصلوا
لاتفاق اليوم يعلن هذا الاتفاق وهذه خطوه
نعتبر انها خطوه جيده مهمه ايضا المنطقه
لا تريد ان تكون طرف لا سمح الله في حال
عمل اي عسكري ضد ايراني لا تريد ان تكون
طرف في هذا العمل ولا ترغب في ان يكون اي
اعتداء هي ايضا تؤكد كل دول منطقه الخليج
بضروره سلطه الدوله المركزيه في ايران وبس
نفوذها هي لا تدعم اي تحركات داخليه هي
تدخل في الشان الداخلي الايراني ولذلك
التاكيد على السياده قضيه مهمه جدا
بالنسبه للطرفين هذه العلاقه واي عادتها
سوف يفتح الباب واسعا لمناقشه كل القضايا
اللي موجوده في المنطقه سواء الامن البحري
سواء امن الطاقه سواء الميليشيات سواء حزب
الله في لبنان الحوثي في اليمن يعني كافه
الملفات والقضايا التي
ربما يعني في وقت من الاوقات كان من الصعب
بحثها او اخذ
القرار المناسب لها ولكن الان اصبحت
الفرصه متاحه ومواتيه بالحوار المباشر
فيما بين الاطراف هنالك موقف خليجي موحد
بشكل عام طبعا هو هذا الموقف
يعني نشهد في الايام القادمه باذن الله
الحوار الدبلوماسي بدايه جيده قد يراها
المحللون والمتابعون ولكن السؤال محمد
صالح صدقيان الى اين يمكن ان تؤدي في
الميلادات الخلافيه بين الطرفين وعلى
راسها اليمن
ان يعتقد بان الجانبان او البلدان ايران
والسعوديه قد وصل الى قناعه مشتركه وهو
انه من يكون رابحا في هذا الاحتكاك او هذا
التدافع الامني الذي استمر اكثر من سبعه
سنوات
من هو الرابح هو الخاسر ايضا لان هذه
المنطقه
تحتوي على الكثير من الدول ايران دوله
كبيره في هذه المنطقه والسعوديه ايضا دوله
كبيره في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي وصل الى
قناعه مشتركه وهو ان هذا التدافع لا يخدم
مصالح اي من البلدين كما انه لا يخدم
مصالح دول وشعوب هذه المنطقه وبالتالي انا
اعتقد بان كافه الملفات العالقه والشائكه
بما في ذلك الملف اليمني هو كان موجودا
على طاوله الحوار السعودي
الايراني الصيني في بكين وبالتالي يعني
اعتقد بان هناك الكثير من الدول وشعوب هذه
منطقه سوف تكون مستفيده من التقارب
الايراني السعودي من اعاده العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه وبالتالي شخصيا اتطلع
وكن دائما اقول بان الحوار يعني لا بد من
الحوار بين ايران ودول المنطقه وتحديدا
الدول الخليجيه الان هذه الخطوه خطوه في
غايه الاهميه لانهاء هذا التدافع الامني
في المنطقه وبالتالي كل الملفات العالقه
وشائكه منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات انا اعتقد
بانها سوف تستفيد من هذا التقارب الان منذ
خمس ساعات ولحد الان يعني منذ اعلان
البيان المشترك السعودي الايراني الصيني
كل الدول وكل الاطراف في المنطقه وحتى
خارج المنطقه رحبت بهذا التقارب سواء كانت
اركان العراق او سلطنه عمان او الدول
الخليجيه الدول الكبرى رحبت
لان جميع الاطراف المعنيه
هذا بالتاكيد اسرائيل لا تريد اي تقارب
اقليمي اقليمي
واسرائيل تريد التازيم تريد التقسيم تريد
تقسيم المقسم وتجزئه المجازع انا لا اتحدث
عن اسرائيل ان يتحدث عن كل الاطراف
المعنيه بالعلاقات الاقليميه بالوضع في
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه رحبت سواء
كانت في لبنان في العراق في سلطنه عمان في
الدوحه في اكثر من منطقه هي رحبت في هذا
التقارب وان يعتقد بانه يصب بمصلحه كل دول
وشعوب هذه المنطقه دكتور
عبد العزيز صقر في النهايه هذا البيان
المشترك الصيني السعودي
الايراني هل يمكن ان نقول انه يتضمن رساله
ربما
تتجاوز هذه الدول الثلاث الى ما هو اوسع
يعني بالتاكيد حينما تكون العلاقه متميزه
بين المملكه وايران تعود الى طبيعتها والى
مكان عليه لانه ايضا البيان اشار الى
الاتفاقيات الاقتصاديه والامنيه التي سبق
تم توقيعها ما بين البلدين فهذا سوف يعني
هنالك انفتاح وهنالك توجه الى علاقه
اقتصاديه علاقه تجاريه متميزه العلاقه في
الطاقه ايضا ايرانيه عضو في منظمه الاوبك
فيعني سوف يدعم اشياء يعني التوجهات كثيره
ربما لا يروق هذا الاتفاق للبعض بالذات
الذين يرون ان مصلحتهم في التصعيد في
المنطقه من ناحيه عسكريه وامنيه ولكن ان
شاء الله نتجاوز هذه المرحله لانه انا
دائما تقول البعض تقصد من تحديدا يعني انت
ذكرتي اسرائيل انه ليس لها مصلحه في ان
ترى يعني هذا باتفاق مثل مثل هذا الاتفاق
يكون موجود لانه اسرائيل هي ترى انه يعني
ما زالت تصنف ايران بالنسبه لها من ناحيه
بالذات البرنامج الن لديها موقف يختلف عن
الكل ونحن لاحظنا هذا الاسبوع كان اجتماع
بين مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ومستشار
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
لمحاوله الاقناع بالعمل العسكري المشتركه
الذي ربما يعني
يصير عليه مفاهمه من الجانبين فهنالك
مصلحه مختلفه لانه اسرائيل الوحده لا
تستطيع ان تنفذ عمل في مواجهه ايران بحاجه
الى صقر يعني المملكه بدا في الفتره
الاخيره وكانها تبتعد قليلا عن واشنطن
تنتخط لنفسها مسارا اكثر استقلاليه هل
يمكن النظر الى هذا التقارب الجديد او
البيان المشترك من خلال هذه الالعاب ايضا
ايضا المملكه حينما زار الرئيس بايدن يعني
جدا العام الماضي وكانت قمه جده العربيه
والخليجيه مع الرئيس الامريكي كان له اربع
مطالب هو اراد ان ان تدان روسيا بشكل كبير
وهو اراد ان يتم زياده رفع الانتاج وهو
اراد ايضا
ان نخرج من الاوبك بلس وهو ايضا اراد ان
نخفض من علاقتنا مع الصين ولكن كل هذه
المطالب لم تنفذ لان الدول الخليج رات ان
توصل رساله واضحه بما فيها مجتمعه مع
المملكه بانها لم تعد تلك الدول التي
تتلقى التعليمات والاوامر هنالك مصالح
مشتركه اذا انا لم اكن حليف استراتيجي
وانا شريك استراتيجي في الشريك له حقوق
عليه واجبات فاذا اردت انت مصالحك ان تلبى
هنالك مصالح خليجيه يجب ان تؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار وعدم اخذا بعين الاعتبار يعني ان
هنالك استقلاليه في القرار نحن لا يعني
نحن لا نعتقد ان الصين بديل هي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في علاقتها مع المنطقه
ولكن ايضا نريد ان نؤكد بان المواقف هنا
تنطلق من مصالح الدول والدول هذا محاوله
ان تؤكد عليه ويؤكد عليه مسؤولينها في
لقاءات لنتوقف عند ردود الفعل على هذا
الاعلان عديده هي المواقف الدوليه التي
رحبت بالاعلان عن الاتفاق بين السعوديه وا
على اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين نستعرض بعضها البلد الراعي
للمحادثات وهو الصين قال على لسان كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين
محادثات وحوار السعوديه وايران في بيجين
نصر للسلام اما الولايات المتحده فقالت
انها كانت على علم بالاتصالات السعوديه
الايرانيه مشيره عبر المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي فيها جون كربي الى ان ما يهم
واشنطن هو انهاء الحرب في اليمن ووقف
الهجمات على السعوديه مضيفا سننتظر ونرى
ما اذا كانت ايران ستفي بالتزاماتها بعد
ابرامها الاتفاقيه مع السعوديه وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه نقلت عن مسؤول اسرائيليين
قوله ان الاتفاق السعوديه الايراني سيؤثر
على امكانيه تطبيع العلاقات بين الرياض
وتل ابيب الخارجيه العراقيه التي لعبت
دورا في تقريب الشقه بين طهران والرياض
عبرت عن ترحيبها بالاتفاق عسى ان عسى ان
يكون فاتحه صفحه جديده من العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين والخارجيه
التركيه ايضا اكدت ان استئناف العلاقات
بين ايران والسعوديه خطوه هامه ستسهم في
امن المنطقه واستقرارها ومن جهتها اكدت
الخارجيه اللبنانيه التي فوق السعوديه
وايران سيترك اثره الايجابيه على مجمل
العلاقات الاقليميه والامين العام لحزب
الله حسن نصر الله وصف الاتفاق بكونه
تحولا جيدا في المنطقه قال سعداء باستئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين ولدين
ثقه ان ذلك سيكون لمصلحه شعوب المنطقه
ودولها ومن ضمنها لبنان
بدوره لم يغب الحوثيون عن التفاعل مع هذه
المستجدات قال الناطق باسم انصار الله
الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام ان المنطقه
بحاجه لعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه بين دوله
اذا واضح من خلال ردود الفعل العديده
ترحيب كبير ربما طبعا كما ذكرنا باستثناء
اسرائيل ونوع من القلق والحذر لدى واشنطن
من ان هناك ما زالت ازمه ثقه محمد صالح
الصدقيان هل يمكن القول ان الاعلان اليوم
يردم هذه الهوه بين البلدين ويعيد الثقه
اما زال امامنا ما ننتظر ان نراه كما تقول
واشد
ان يعتقد بان القياده السياسيه في ايران
والقياده السياسيه في السعوديه
توصل الى قناعه كما قلت هذه القناعه تقول
بانه
مجالات التعاون والتنسيق بين البلدين ربما
تستطيع ان تثي بمصالح البلدين المشتركه في
الاقليم وبالتالي هذا التناحر الذي كان او
هذا
التدافع الامني الذي كان منذ عشر سنوات
لحد الان في الاقليم بين الرياض
وطهران وربما وصل الى نهايه لم تكن مشجعه
لا للسعوديه ولا لايران ولا لدول المنطقه
ولا للملفات الشائكه في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي ان يعتقد بان هناك رغبه لدى
الجانبين السعودي والايراني من اجل التوصل
الى اليات للتعاون والتنسيق لحل المشاكل
الموجوده والعالقه في المنطقه ومن اجل بدء
صفحه جديده في العلاقات كما سمعناها باكثر
من الجانب السعودي من جانب الايراني
واعتقد في هذه المره هناك نوع من الاعاده
لحل هذه المشاكل والاتجاه باتجاه التعاون
والتنسيق بين البلدين ذكرت كلمه اليات
وهنا اسالك دكتور عبد العزيز صقر هل لدى
طهران والرياض
خارطه الطريق ربما وفقها يتم
يعني تلمس اثر حقيقي لهذا التقارب هل فعلا
يمكن
التفاؤل بشان العلاقات في المنطقه
وتاثيرها على المنطقه كما سمعنا من اكثر
من طرف يعني حينما تكون العلاقه جيده
ومتميزه وليس فيها اي تصعيد او تدخل في
الشان الداخلي فيما بين ايران وبقيه دول
المنطقه هذا بالتاكيد راح يدفع الى اتجاه
سلم والى اتجاه تنمو بعظيم ايران بلد
كبيره وجاره شقيقه نريد ان تكون لنا افضل
علاقات معها لا نق عليها الضيم ولا نقبل
عليها الاعتداء او الحروف ولذلك من ناحيه
مبدئيه نريد لها الاستقرار والامن وان
تزخر وان يعني الشعب الايراني عانى من
الحصار وعان من العقوبات التي فرضت عليها
فنتمنى زوال هذه العقوبات عليهم وايضا ان
يعودوا الى المجتمع الدولي باكثر فاعليه
وانجازيه تخيلي حينما تكون ايران بحجم
سكانها وبموقعها الجغرافي والدول الجوار
المحيطه بها وبانتاجها للطاقه مع دول في
المنطقه هنا يكون بينهم تعاون كم ممكن
يكون الفائده العظيمه للطرفين وهذا كلام
سبق انه القيادتين اكدوا ولكن مع الاسف
الشديد في مراحل معينه كان البعض يعني
ربما لا يرغبون في هذا الحوار يعني اليوم
ما وصلنا اليه من النتيجه سبقته سنوات من
الحوار على فكره سواء على المسار الثاني
او المسار الاول واحد ونصف مثل ما يسمى
اللي هو المختلط ما بين مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني والرسمي او الاجتماع الرسمي اللي
صار الخمس اجتماعات التي حدثت كتبت لهذه
العلاقه فهذه كلها سوف تقود ان شاء الله
الى وضع افضل اولا خفض التصعيد المفاهمه
المباشره الحوار المباشر ما بين الطرفين
يعني الايران كانوا من اكبر المعتمرين
الذين يزورون المملكه وحجاجها وهم ايضا
حرموا في السنوات الماضيه بسبب اوضاعهم
الاقتصاديه وعدم الامكانيات من العوده الى
هذا المملكه تفتح ذراعيها مستعده اذا
تقدمت ايران خطوه نحو السلام والاستقرار
في المنطقه في المملكه ودول البقيه دول
الخليج مستعده ان تخطو خطوات اكثر بكثير
نحو هذا الاتجاه
ربما دكتور محمد صالح صدقيان فيما يتعلق
بما ذكر الدكتور عبد العزيز يعني الخطوات
القادمه نتحدث عن فتح سفرتين خلال شهرين
لدى البلدين ولكن ماذا بعد كيف ستتعامل
طهران مع التحفظ الامريكي
والتشكيك وايضا الغضب الاسرائيلي
المكتوم والمعلم ايضا
دعيني اشير الى ما قاله علي شمخاني الذي
قاد الوفد لايراني في بكين هو قال بان
المباحثات كانت في غايه الشفافيه والوضوح
ايضا معنى ذلك بانه تب مناقشه الكثير من
القضايا العالقه بين البلدين وهذا شيء مهم
جدا انا كنت دائما ادعو الى وضع كافه
الامور على الطاوله بين بين طهران
والسعوديه من اجل التفاهم حتى ولو كان على
الحد الادنى من هذا التفاهم شخصيا انا
متفائل جدا وكم يعني لا اخفي ارتياح شديد
منذ عصر هذا اليوم عندما سمعت البيان
المشترك لحد الان وانا اعتقد بان ما تم
معالجتي وما تم مناقشته في بكين من
القضايا التي طرحت على الطاوله انا اعتقد
بانها كانت في غايه الاهميه متفائل
لمستقبل العلاقات بين طهران
والرياض ومتفائل ايضا بالاليات التي ممكن
تنفيذها يجب علينا ان ننتظر اللقاء الذي
سوف يكون على مستوى دبلوماسي بين وزير
خارجيه البلدين وانا اعتقد بان هناك رغبه
لدى الحكومه الايرانيه من اجل التوصل الى
تفاهمات دبلوماسيه للاسراع في اعاده
العلاقات وفتح
السفارتين في طهران وفي الرياض
اسمحوا لي ان اختم الحلقه عباره بعثها
لصديق قبل الحلقه قال اطلبوا الصلح ولو في
الصين على العموم اشكركما الضيفي الكريمين
محمد صالح صدقيان الباحث المتخصص في
القضايا الاقليميه وشكرا جزيلا دكتور عبد
العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز الخليج للابحاث
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا في
[موسيقى]